let me use hell week this is a perfect
example hell week's 130 hours
and 130 hours is a lot of seconds
a lot of seconds
and if you lose let's say you win every
second but one
you lost
it only takes one second for you to lose
the whole thing so the one second
decision is just that
you're in a situation where life is
sucking let's say you're in extreme cold
water
and your life is flashing before your
eyes every time that wave goes over your
head your thought processes
I gotta get the [__] out of this water
and you're in hell week
and your hour one of 130 hours
it's all fun and games okay because at
the beginning of Hell Week the guns are
going off it's like a pep rally so
you're hyped up and your boys are linked
arms and you're getting sprayed and it's
like a pep rally there's structure
yelling at your bombs are going off
concussion grenades blanks from in 60s
yeah yeah yeah
[__] yeah
but then what they do is they shut that
[__] off
they shut it off
all that huyah all that hype it gets
real quiet
and they March you out to that surf zone
for something called surf torture
and it's that water that Pacific Ocean
is coldish
so no more pep rally you're now in your
head
you're linked arms with you know your
brothers beside you you don't know if
they could be there long or not you
don't care anything about yourself
you lay back and that first wave hits
you
your mind
goes straight from hour to
all the way to hour 130. you can't
process five days
you're now you're you're now in a you
like I gotta get out of here you're in
fight or flight it's cold I can't be
cold this long
and then this that one second decision
comes in
you forgot every reason why you wanted
to be there
you don't care about seals you don't
care about any of this you don't care
about fighting for your country you
don't care about that gaudy goat Trident
that they put on your chair you don't
care about that no more all you want to
do is go back home you want the warmth
you may want something to eat you want
your girl to hold you all those things
of comfort are there in that one second
and this is where people lose
so what I do in that one second because
we all think about quitting it's hard
but what you have to do in that one
second is hard to process information
during pain
because that pain takes over
and you can't think rationally
you're thinking about fight or flight
save yourself that's not a rational
thought it's not a thought that's going
to get you through
hard times
most people fail that one second so what
happens what I do in that one second and
there's a bigger process to all this but
in that one second
I physically stayed in that water
because if I get out of the water I quit
so I physically stay in the water but
mentally
I'm on the beach with the instructors
and the instructors it's cold outside so
they got these Parkers on they got their
cup of Joe and they're warm because
they've already been through it so now
it's your turn to go through it
so many I get back with them I'm still
in the water physically but mainly I'm
back with you I'm chilling I got my
Parker on and now I'm thinking logically
because I'm warm now mentally I'm warm
I've taken that one second
let's not quit yet guys let's think
about your options
where are you going to end up if you
quit this [__] where are you going to go
where are you going to say to yourself
because you know you're going to get
warm the second you get out of this
water you're gonna take a shower
and you can be warm and you could be and
in five days you could be out so I start
thinking logically
I calm my brain down because your brain
just wants to get the [__] out ring the
bell put your helmet down get warm and
then you're really [__]
and these are the things you have to
think about the one second decision so
that's that's all about it's about
gaining control of your mind
putting things back in the proper
perspective
and then saying
I really do want to be here
and I'm gonna have a bunch of these one
seconds through this 130 hour Journey
and I have to learn to control these
because if I fail one of these one
seconds I will not be a seal I will not
be a doctor I will not be a lawyer or
not be whatever the [__] it is so that's
how important that one second decision
is it's all about your mind taste
control you you have to say [__] you
I run this [__]
and that's what that's all about
projecting yourself forward to see
what are the consequences of failing
what are the consequences of stopping
yep is about as powerful of a motivation
strategy as I can think of you know
because what you're doing is you're
trying to optimize right now to stop the
discomfort that's right but what you're
going to pay for that in is shame and
guilt and regret long term that's right
so what you need to be able to do is
bundle all of that up that is as yet
unfelt but will last for way way way
longer you know the future is much
longer than now that's right the future
is going to extend out up until the day
that you die and the now is just for now
and even 130 hours is just 130 hours
that's right and you get to look back
and you look back with Pride and Glory
why'd you look back with shame and guilt
that's it that's that's the one second
you just summarized it right there and
most people feel those one seconds
and then that one second leads to 20
years 30 years 40 Years of [__] I have
people who have been through training
with me Ranger schools SEAL training Air
Force training and I get calls from them
today and they have great lives and all
they talk about is how they failed in
that one moment
and they can't even
break they can't even enjoy their life
now
because they're now warm
they're now warm there's no more
suffering there's no more suffering for
me either and we're in the same boat now
but you're suffering and I would so
we're not suffering
but you're thinking about what you could
have been
I am exactly what I should have been
and that's where people start to lose it
because now I I realize that in that one
second I go through all that I know how
it's going to feel because I failed so
many times before
failure is the ultimate thing man I
failed so many times before that's why I
look at failure anymore it's failure I
look as my first second and third
attempt
so that's what that's all about man well
I mean he went back to go and do Moab
again a second time right which is your
second attempt that's right
had you banged your knee up it was
pretty bad in between the first and the
second one it was pretty bad way before
either one of them uh-huh yeah yeah it
was it's been jacked up now for about 20
years I've seen some gnarly photos of it
recently it looks yeah interesting yeah
so all those miles I've run on this
thing is it's uh it's been a lot of uh
it's been a lot of gut checks
so you go back you do Moab a second time
yep and then you turn your ass into like
a hamburger or something as well so it's
not just the knee it's the ass as well
now yeah so at Mile 201
we have a good video of it matter of
fact
Jennifer is like there's some people up
there so at at so 201 is a spot where I
was really finished in the first Moab so
that was a
um it was a way market checkpoint yeah
the second time so Jennifer is extremely
happy right now because I'm there yes
and she knows I'm doing well now I'm
doing good we're gonna get through this
and so she's videoing me as I'm coming
up this climb on this road and she goes
there's some people up here who want to
meet you you're doing so amazing I said
my ass is [__] up you need to get the
[__] Desitin cream and it's literally
for like 20 [__] miles
that like people don't get it man when
you get raw like that bro
and you're walking because you the
chafing of my ass it was hamburger meat
and I'm like so she's all [__] happy
and [__] she's and I just look at her
and I'm gonna put the video up on social
media because it's but she's a [__]
Trooper bro hang on so could she was a
leakage oh yeah that was on the video
from behind
so my shorts were absolutely raw dogged
yeah so when you pull them down it's
just blood
and so she goes in the bathroom because
she didn't know what she was gonna see
she has a Desitin cream she walks in
there
and
I pull him down and spread them open and
I go put that [__] all up in there so
she goes in for the kill and she's
putting this Dustin cream all over the
[__] place man and you know what
that's the funny thing about it
that's when you know you got a good
[__] with you man when you're
that raw and you're that [__] up and
she's just like nothing it was like
saying hey can you like put some lotion
on my back before I go lay out that's
how she was in there man getting in it
That's it man have you considered that
that might be the most traumatic event
of all of the things that you've done in
your life what you ask Jennifer to do
that day no not at all she did worse
so that Leadville chapter when I talk
about after I finished
and then the ultra raveling or
unraveling had begun when I lay down so
oh that was on the duvet and you didn't
know the word duvet yeah I know what the
[__] dude
blanket man okay yeah fair enough count
from the streets we call them blankets
okay anything that you wrap up is a
[__] blanket cool
so I'm laying on the duvet
and she's all [__] like about her
damn rating is that [__] the Airbnb
[__] and I'm really like hey I'm about
to [__] because it's not your place no
okay no right yes I can see that scene
is uh is is was was bad but once again
like a crime scene it's yes it was a
crime scene this episode is brought to
you by element element is a tasty
electrolyte drink mix with everything
that you need and nothing that you don't
I've replaced my morning coffee with
element every day for over three years
now and I've never looked back it means
I've optimized my hydration my brain
feels better I'm not getting mental fog
and it's helping me to curb Cravings if
I'm fasting throughout the day even
video guy Dean uses it my favorite
flavor is the orange that in a cold
glass of water upon waking feels really
really good it's a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of sodium potassium
and magnesium which helps me to fill up
my absolute best all day also they have
a no BS no questions asked refund policy
so you can buy it and try it for an
unlimited amount of time and if you do
not like it they'll give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how confident they are
that you love it head to drink lmnt dot
com slash modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Goggins then press here for the full
episode in all of its glory and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]